hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're going to be looking at
what's the fastest way to loop in python
so just as an example task
we're going to loop through the numbers
0 to n
minus 1 where n is going to be some big
number like this
and just add them up you know something
to do in the loop
which one do you think is faster using a
while loop or a for loop
you can see in both cases we're doing
essentially
the same work but one of them is using a
while loop
and the other one is using a for loop in
both cases
we initialize a sum to zero and then
loop over all the numbers
adding to the sum we'll test to see
which one is fastest
by using the time it method from the
timing library
let's just go ahead and run it okay and
you can already see
that it took a surprising amount of time
over 15 seconds for the while loop
but just under 10 seconds for the for
loop so it looks like
the for loop is the clear winner in this
case i would like to point out that i
am recording this at the same time that
i'm running this code
so these numbers are largely inflated
but if you run the code at home
and i have done this you will find that
the ratios are approximately the same
so we saw that although the for loop and
the while loop are doing essentially the
same thing
the while loop took over five seconds
longer
why is that well the unfortunate fact of
the matter
is that compared to the c programming
language that python is written in
python itself is an extremely slow
language
in order to do the for loop python
passes the iteration off to
c code that works with the iterator of
this range object
that's all written in c so all of the
iteration
part of it is actually done in c
all the bounds checking and incrementing
of this variable i
is done in c and it's only this
statement which is actually done in
python
in contrast in the while loop both the
check to see whether i is less than n
and incrementing i
both of those things are done in python
not in c
we can confirm that this is actually the
issue by adding in
these functions so what these functions
do these are
modifications of this for loop function
that add in
a redundant operation that doesn't
actually need to be there
so in this one we add in the increment
so we increment i now of course
this variable i is going to be
incremented by the range iterator on its
own
so this i plus equals 1 actually has no
noticeable effect
besides running and taking up time
similarly in this one we add in this
redundant check
to see whether i is less than n and then
in this one
we add in both the check to see if i is
less than n
and the redundant increment
so i've just given them their own lines
in the time it code and let's go ahead
and run it again and see how long they
take
so as you can see just adding in these
redundant operations
to the for loop implementation that it
significantly increased the time
this i plus equals 1 shouldn't really do
anything
but adding that in alone has practically
made
the for loop as slow as the while loop
similarly we can see that adding in the
redundant if
i is less than n check also adds a few
seconds to the computation
then worst of all is doing both the
redundant
i plus equals 1 and test to see if i
is less than n that's coming in at
around
19 seconds making it the slowest one
and showing us that doing these useless
operations
just because they're in python and not
in c even though they have no real
effect
is really slowing our code down
okay that's pretty sad so is there
anything that we can do to go
faster than a for loop or a while loop
one thing that should come to mind
is use built-ins over loops whenever you
can
so this implementation uses the built-in
sum which does a for loop under the hood
uh and the built-in range of course
rather than writing the loop ourselves
so let's see how fast that goes
wow that is a lot better than both the
for loop and the while loop
so you can see if ever you have the
ability to use a built-in
over an actual loop you should
definitely take that route but can we do
even better than that
how about let's try using numpy which is
built for doing these kind of operations
quickly
i went ahead and imported numpy and
added this
some numpy function the numpy sum
just creates the range as a numpy range
and then uses the numpy.sum to sum it up
so this is essentially equivalent to
this one but it's using numpy functions
instead of python functions and again
numpy is primarily written in c
so as much of this as possible should be
happening in c not python
let's try running it again okay so that
one was
much faster compared to the others this
is the only good one
because the entire summing operation is
written in c this whole function
essentially is one c
call so both the iteration
but also the adding itself is done
in c and that's what makes this one the
fastest of them all
the only downside to this one is that
this creation of a range
actually creates that whole array in
memory so
i just made a 100 million element array
in memory so if i had chosen a bigger
number i might not have enough memory to
do that
comparatively this sum range this range
doesn't actually create all those
elements in memory
so this sum could actually run no matter
how big n is without
worrying about memory constraints but in
this case i think it's definitely worth
it
to give up the memory and let the sum
happen
in c rather than python so you might be
asking
is there anything that we can do to beat
out numpy you would be hard-pressed to
find
a faster implementation even in c
for this sum operation i think numpy
does a really good job at making this
happen quickly
so the only feasible way of making this
happen faster
is to know the answer ahead of time
that's why
the final implementation is to use math
knowledge
what are we doing we're adding up the
first n minus 1
integers well there's a formula for that
you may not know it but you can
certainly look it up and here it is
so this is pure python and it's going to
beat out the c1
for sure by a lot let's go ahead and
test it
and of course it is no contest the pure
math implementation
is not even in the same league numpy
is good but knowing the answer ahead of
time you just can't compete with that
in conclusion what's the fastest way to
loop in python
well the unfortunate truth of the matter
is the fastest way to loop in python
is not to loop in python if you have the
great luxury of being able to compute
the answer
mathematically ahead of time definitely
do that
your next best option is to have the
whole looping
and everything that you want to do be
done in a pure
c function your next best option is to
call a pure c function that can do all
of the looping
and your operations for you failing that
use python built-ins like sum or map
rather than writing a loop yourself as a
last resort
use a for loop over a while loop
hey thanks for watching if you liked the
video don't forget to
leave a like a comment and if you
especially liked the video don't forget
to subscribe it really helps me out
thanks see you in the next one